backlash in America as I mentioned there
Donald Trump Gabby how's he still
clinging on do you think you will
actually make the election in November I
mean serious allegation it's amazing
when this story thing like this Ridge is
both shocking profoundly shocking
because you've got here someone who
wants to be President basically saying
woohoo I committed an indecent assault
Mike and get away with it but also
really unsurprising this doesn't tell us
anything about Trump really that we
couldn't already have guessed and you
think if he's made it this far in the
campaign based on what we know about him
I don't think this is gonna stop him and
yet did the whole field brain is saying
he can't carry on after this and the
other half is saying or what else is
going to happen I mean the only thing
that could realistically happen this
time is Mike's Mike Pence steps instead
of him as the candidate but yeah I mean
I'd whether they were procedures in
place for that mean we're in unknown
territory but but you know it does seem
that he's he's getting pretty close to
to have him to withdraw that something
else like this comes out one thing I'm
not so sure I tend to presume that he's
judged by a different standard to the
way that any other politician is of
course any other politician would have
to step down it would be impossible for
them to continue but he is more akin to
a comedian really than he is a
politician they like the tone of the way
he talks that no-nonsense approach and
he keeps referring to the reality a show
to the apprentice doesn't absolutely
well if you think about the way they
hear just the fox news anchor when she
supposedly gave him a few hours showing
exactly and suddenly something about
menstruation issues like that he doesn't
suffer any effect from that he's quite
clearly this monstrous misogynist that
hasn't stopped him so far so I just
don't see why this further step down
that road would be any different to
what's come before & Marting the idea
you know all these senior Republican
cells that were left supporting him even
those disappearing John McCain Irish
warts & Eggar others as well yeah well
he's being abandoned left right and
center from Republicans now it is really
important more mike pence does but it's
also interesting to see how our
politicians are reacting to it so this
morning you've had Michael Fallon the
defense secretary saying I don't want to
get involved in American politics and
Justine Greening the education secretary
saying these are crass Commons which of
course anyone normal onlooker would
would agree with and so it all sets it
up Gabi for the debate this evening my
goodness me is he going to take it on
the chin and say I'm a sinner that
repenteth or a tackler e Clinton over a
husband
sort of half apologizing you know
fantastic Trump apology very basic says
that's not the real me apparently the
real me is the one when the cameras are
rolling and the one cut off camera it's
not the real remember after last debate
he complained about a dodgy microphone
exactly there was one I think he'll go
after built he'll just say you know will
your husband and it doesn't exactly have
the world's best track record with women
which might work if Bill Clinton was
actually the candidate but he's not I
presume he'll just try and bluster out
but I think you'll be talking to that
bit of the audience the Trump audience
that does it care who he is it just
likes the ideas that knows that no one
else is going to come in on in American
politics thing quite the same things and
therefore that's what they want if they
want you know to bar every Muslim from
America and build a wall with Mexico
then he's the only choice I mean but you
think that's enough Michael to get him
over the line you know we talked about
okay there's there there's the committed
Trump bikes too committed Republicans
who will vote for him come whatever but
you know you've got to attract some of
the swing voters you know I think what
the problem for him here really is
there's a big section of American voters
who are very conservative and it might
be the vulgarity rather than the
misogyny that actually sinks in here the
morality as well I mean talking bible
belt support here aren't they they're
going to say well this isn't the kind of
thing we want to hear that'll be a
problem then it looks currently as if
it's so much of a problem that he won't
succeed however what we see in Britain
what we see actually in Scotland as well
we see throughout Europe and in America
are a core set of voters who want to
kick the status quo no matter what you
present to them is a significant change
from the way the system operates now
they will go for that that's the vote
that he's operating towards it looks
like he's alienated enough people but
even that boat may not be enough to get
him over the line but that key
anti-establishment anti elite vote I
still think that he will Hoover it up
well stay with that thought and apply it
to the United Kingdom or what we heard
in particular last week from Theresa May
and indeed other senior government
figures she's trying to capture that
vote yet having been part of that
political establishment herself for many
many years it was extraordinary sight
you always see would you see a prime
minister stand up and say when I'm
taking on the elites and you sort of
think what this is baffling even on its
own terms she'd been home secretary for
six years before it so there's only so
far she could go that however I suspect
that some of the policies she was
putting forward much as I disagree with
them on immigration and on that sort of
idea
on the market of being able to interfere
in the market will actually appeal to
many working-class voters who might have
been previously would've voted labour
might have been toying with voting you
get so there is more policy meat on the
bones of that message but still it's
innately absurd for a politician to be
making it but I mean we've got this idea
Michael you know Steve Hilton former
adviser to David Cameron saying today
and he was was of course a prominent
leave campaign is saying some of these
policies are repugnant yeah you've got
an interesting situation here where
Theresa May formerly in the Home Office
has put immigration right at the center
of this brexit debate and there's a sort
of strange retreat for liberal Britain
in a way where are the sort of liberal
voices in the cabinet in the government
in the opposition who are really going
to make the arguments that the economy
should come first is it going to be
Philip Hammond he was out in Washington
the day after the Prime Minister's
speech making the point that we
shouldn't be too hasty about what this
means you know the liberal voice for
Britain now is a really interesting one
where is it going to come from yeah well
we're hearing then they've gone
underground gabi that you know the
Chancellor might be one of the more
things about the home secretary herself
who made some of those statements now I
remember in the in the campaign debates
when you know she had a great zinger
didn't she on Boris Johnson that the
kind of guy who'd like to party with but
you wouldn't wanted to drive you home I
was watching Nicky Morgan on your
program earlier you know she was very
much Saints not the amber I know this is
not and you look amber and I think come
on this is not your policy it's been
dumped on you from above the idea of
getting companies to publish lists
published data on how many foreign
workers they have and they're
interesting these signs this morning
they're rowing back on that looks like
government is now saying oh well we
weren't force people to publish the
information because obviously business
has been saying to them you know we
don't want a brick through our windows
because someone objects to the number of
Romanians we've been hiring you know so
I think we're now going to end up in a
situation where they quietly retreat
from that idea on it yeah but it also
seems I mean throwing it across the
English Channel and I mean it also seems
to be upsetting your event you know that
the pushback we're getting from the
likes of President Hollande and indeed
the Chancellor Angela Merkel can't even
start negotiating with us with those
kind of like and how long's comments
some people suspect her actually what
triggered that precipitous drop in the
pound immediately after him
read them there's no overstating just
how alienated European leaders are by
the way that we're talking about these
issues it's not just the deterioration
of our standards when we start talking
on immigration it's that we don't seem
to have any comprehension of what is
involved in a European negotiation we
have brickset ministers that still talk
as if they're entitled to bilateral
trade deals with European member states
which they are not entitled to and then
we have an attitude so it says its
equivalent saying well I'm look I'm
going to go to Prague but I refuse to
follow any of the rules if we're saying
we want to be in the single market but
we're going to put whatever we want on
our own products and we're going to cut
freedom movement and not respond to the
European Central Bank then they're
obviously not going to take a cell rich
swirling round but I mean throw into
that then Michael the idea that the
brexit vote was in part about
reasserting the sovereignty of
Parliament but then as many my guests
pointing out to me this morning and
reading in the newspaper saying well
hold on none of this seems to be going
before Parliament for a vote yeah well
I'll make one prediction which is always
dangerous in politics the skullduggery
in parliament on brexit has not even
begun it will go on months after month
they'll find ways of having votes over
just about everything you know it's
going to be fun times on the green
benches I think because you're going to
get people manufacturing votes about all
the issues they're worried about it's
going to be interesting picking it apart
and what about this I mentioned the
Chancellor Gaby reading in the paper
today unnamed minister saying he's gotta
watch his back yes it's been a bit of
briefing from the Treasury about the
three brexit ministers davis fox &
johnson site leave you to guess who
might have it in perfect almond but
there are clearly tensions only cuz the
Chancellor the Chancellor is the person
who is constantly dealing with the city
and with business which is terrifying
you know what the implications for
brexit are he's always going to be kind
of fighting their corner in cabinets
there's going to be a little bit of
tension there between the two but you
can really see the relationship between
Philip Hammond and Theresa May emerging
as you know we've been here before
tensions between a Chancellor and prime
minister but that's the key relationship
I wonder when you want to come in on
that I mean there is this sort of
element where he comes out he says the
precise opposite of what Theresa May was
saying in a speech when he was talking
to Bloomberg the next day he says what
comes first originally obviously single
market membership comes before
immigration you couldn't get further
away from what she say when he talks to
the guys in the city as soon as she
makes that speech the Monday morning
afterwards they start thinking what are
the
is that we start transferring to Europe
in order we can demonstrate to local
regulators we have a significant enough
presence that we can maintain pass
porting so the city was already changing
he's trying to reflect that reality and
the more he does that I think the more
untenable his position becomes because
well he's clearly not on the same page i
watch what's so interesting is in that
six years of the Cameron government
cameron and osborne could barely get a
cigarette paper between the two of them
and goodness knows people tried
absolutely and this is very dangerous
you've got the treasury pulling in a
different directional Downing Street it
seems already so a back sir Blair Brown
is what you're saying yeah except I mean
to some extent maybe they need to play
good cop bad cop maybe the Prime
Minister needs to talk to those people
who voted for brexit wanting an into
immigration and maybe Hammond needs to
talk to you know to auditory friends in
the city but that's a a very hard act to
pull off when you're essentially talking
at cross-purposes with each it's
interesting isn't it that we have nearly
used up all our time on that issue but
we gotta talk about labour and you know
are they now in a better position in
terms of offering a a credible
opposition of course those are who
remained on and who were appointed to
jeremy corbyn's front Bunce been saying
yes we are but then we're also hearing
michael about some kind of shadow shadow
cabinet freelance operation than the
bottom entry labour party well so it
depends how formalized this is but
certainly you're going to get labor
moderates as they star themselves in
Parliament taking different positions to
Jeremy Corbyn you might also get
differences on policy developing their
own policy through think tanks and other
devices I think what you can say is even
though Jeremy Corbyn has won twice unity
has not amazingly broken out in the
labour party yeah that's a stunning
observation Michael I mean what do you
think you know we got our in Johnson
saying the other day senior figure like
oh and Johnson saying Corbin just isn't
up to it only demonstrably isn't I mean
it's quite clear that he has no very
clear idea of what policy platform we
would have nor any idea of how to speak
to the public however there were some
little diamonds in the rough of that
reshuffle the first one I think is that
there is actually you know a vaguely
competition a brexit minister now so
we're actually going to start seeing
hopes aqui estare exactly from Durga
Public Prosecutions who actually has a
forensic mind who would take a
structured approach what's going on with
Brett said quite unlike Emily Thornberry
who really didn't seem to understand
anything that she was doing she was
breathe weeks after the vote and still
asking what is article 50 and how does
it work she clearly just couldn't get to
grips with it now it looks like at least
on brexit there's going to be a more
structured approach to the way that
labor does obviously but I mean on that
issue of brexit obviously you know the
big existential issues for the next
years to come do they agree the point is
is jeremy corbyn really and remain i was
he remain at huh what does he want well
that's a multi-billion dollar question
the other question is whether because
people suspect him of being a secret
lever the rest is whether I mean if you
have a situation where it's very
difficult to get breaks it through
Parliament you don't know where the
Labour Party is because Corbin can't
really lead the Labour Party in a
particular direction they'll always be a
load of MPs we're going in the opposite
direction him comes much heart of
government to do the maths but I think I
think something happened with this
reshuffle is it is a real it's a
generational shift that didn't happen
last year this is about saying okay you
know literally the whole of the all the
labor people you probably know people
you'd recognize them could pick out of a
lineup they're all over you know we are
into a whole new era where really it is
closest to calming the counts the people
who are prepared to service gone you
know and it will be whether some new
sort of star emerges from that era and
whether there are tensions between those
yeah I can also see that I can hear it
in my head the first Prime Minister's
Questions of the the new session coming
up because that you know the core
members of the labor frontbencher all
from a very small area of London suta
resumes already call them the liberal
elite yeah absolutely and there's this
worried that the jeremy corbyn Labour
Party does just represent a corner of
Islington and that's a problem he's
going to have none of it happening
absolutely to be fair it stretches
across your thunder listen where we're
at a time Michael Ian Gabby very good to
see thank you very much a deeper taking
assert through some of those bigger
issues